hey everyone I'm Ilana and welcome to my
channel I just got home from work and
something kind of crazy has been
announced so I just wanted to make a
quick video talking about it in part
there is a video game award show where
Red Dead Redemption
- isn't nominated for anything so to
give you some backstory
CBS announced gamers Choice Awards it's
going to air on CBS on TV on December
9th and I think that that makes it the
first ever televised gaming award show
it's also obviously coming very soon
after the actual Game Awards but nobody
in the industry knew about this until
today so it's like we've all got our
invitations to the actual Game Awards
already we've all like filled out the
nominee ballots we've I think the cutoff
was literally the 19th for us to vote on
the nominees so like the industry knows
about the cam Awards about Geoff
Keeley's Game Awards nobody's heard of
gamers Choice Awards I know that it's
run by the same company who runs the
Teen Choice Awards so I'm expecting this
to be kid orientated which makes some of
it makes sense so it was already weird
and I was already very curious but then
I looked through the categories and it
gets weird uh I have not looked through
all of them so you might see some
surprises here with me so we have fan
favorite male gameis last rima and fan
favorite female gamer / stream em sure
whatever you weird ones to start out
with but then comes after that but I get
it you going for the stream of play
you're into eSports because television
thinks that's hot [ __ ] right now so we
got a fan favorite game look they didn't
specify a date first game for tonight
that didn't come out in 2018 I don't
know what the category is God of War
good game Marvel spider-man very good
I've watched wrong you didn't come out
this year dragon will fight us very very
good Celeste
League of Legends didn't come out this
year
black ops 4000 screen Odyssey Monster
Hunter world they're all valid picks
I think League is probably the weirdest
one
you were going for stuff that people
stuff that young audiences have
repeatedly been playing then sure but
then why would you not have like destiny
to on here I don't know maybe that's too
mature fan favorite action game all
makes sense
I get that fan favorite single play a
gaming experience Celeste bobble
spider-man got a walleye sows escrito to
see Detroit become human no Red Dead
Redemption - maybe there's some kind of
cutoff date that it didn't make maybe
red didn't make the cut I don't know how
when apparently league of legends makes
the cut the fan favorite game of the
entire year but it's fine fan favorite
shoot a game I love me some good shooter
games fan favorite battle royale game
yeah that checks out Sheol and favorite
indie game that's pretty common
then favorite family-friendly
multiplayer game is suspiciously
specific but ok
I love playing just dance with my family
MMORPG you just listed every popular MMO
really Guild Wars 2 was robbed fan
favorite mobile game fan favorite gaming
device who do you thinks gonna win that
you know what if it's kids I don't
actually know if it's young people who
are voting which by the way I don't know
how anyone votes at this point yet it
hasn't gotten that far I'm not sure if
there's like an online ballot or if
teens somehow vote on the CBS I really
don't know fan favorite retro game who's
your audience who are you making this
for how are you gonna go from a fan
favorite family-friendly game and like
okay it's gonna be is you're gonna have
fortnight's gonna win every category
it's nominated in to not having
retention to to having fan favorite
retro game
it's just so weird fan favorite eSports
moment okay this one specifically is
what makes me think this whole thing is
just an advertiser's play because I can
tell you as someone who has walked in
games media covering eSports is
difficult because most people who watch
eSports only watch one eSport or maybe
two but they usually only dabble in the
one thing so anyone who is looking at
this category which is not going to be
many people is only going to vote for
the one thing that they maybe might
follow nobody's gonna know what this is
it was a weird choice it only makes
sense if you're making a ton of money
off of this thing somehow most desired
franchise resurrection you know what
maybe the whole things for advertisers
if they have jet set radio that's a cool
choice not like that they did that
Banjo Kazooie would probably be my pick
sorry it wasn't half-life you know what
actually I like this one but I'm still
gonna say I think maybe they had to add
in as many things as possible to just
drag the whole thing out so that it
seemed long enough to be able to sell a
certain amount of [ __ ] on like maybe
they're like gee impact with sponsors or
something fan favorite video game
character of the year well I guess of
the year means that we are back to 2018
actually did really like Connor I did
like him band favorite multiplayer game
sure it's weird to not have pub G or GTA
actually if you're gonna have at
whatever you want which clearly you've
got not having GTA 5 in there which is
well now still is the highest-grossing
entertainment product of all time is an
odd choice fan favorite eSports game
alright fan favorite eSports team fan
favorite eSports player fan oh my god
that did putting them down into
categories wow wow you know how many
people gonna tune out for this segment
trust me
if you had asked I would have been like
hell no the amount of people who'll be
watching this who will also care is way
too goddamn small how much money you
getting from sponsors fan favorite
eSports Kostas Jule how does it keep
getting weirder also just I instead of
just I'm going insane
favorite celebrity gamer musician
athlete I didn't know a Fiasco play
video games it's actually pretty sick
favorite and male voice actor okay this
one should say of the year again but
doesn't again all this year gaming
moment over the year so okay there you
go you mentioned it here Red Dead
Redemption 2 has the biggest opening
weekend of any entertainment property so
you've recognized that Red Dead
Redemption 2 exists we didn't nominate
it for anything other than a moment
which is it made a lot of money response
is unhappy with Red Dead Redemption - is
that what happened it's not
family-friendly enough is that it who
why you know what when I started the
city of full disclosure I didn't think
that it would be me slowly deteriorating
into madness I wasn't mad when I started
it is interesting that there's so many
streaming awards and not many YouTube
awards that is like because even the
eSports caster Awards are technically
streaming ones but I don't know you guys
I'm perplexed oh wait you can sign up in
it for an account and vote hero you can
vote so it is just just the public just
the Internet is going to vote you know
what you know how this is gonna work
people are just going to vote bomb let
me sign up and just see if there's
anything that I have to do like do I
have to give an edge or anything Ilana
peace
you can vote every hour I'm gonna cut
out my email address it gets better
so I signed in and then and then you go
to your actual email and it just says
here's you sign an info and then it
gives you your own email address this
seems like it might be a scam oh my god
it's also one I didn't I didn't know who
that is
it's one of those things where you just
you just click and then and then it but
you can't put in anything else God of
War wow I hate this whoo wait what wait
what this wasn't on the on the list okay
fan favorite full release I guess this
is for the games that didn't cut it in
the other categories there we go Red
Dead Redemption - is that maybe they
added it in off the people commented
about it not being there how weird
already friends thank you for coming on
this weird journey with me right at
redemption - is my favorite fall game of
the year I haven't made many videos
lately all streamed lately because I've
been super sick the fires have been
killing me and I have chronic fatigue
and that's been playing up so I've been
actually in hospital a bit which sucks
but I will get back to it when I can I
love you all and I will see you guys
next time bye bye